do you think she's just drunk at karaoke
and she's like she's like in the music's
Lounge she's like I'm trying to ride the
Jew thing like we'll see how it goes
I think it's hot I think it's gonna work
I just found out I'm 30 Jewish and she's
like how [ __ ] lost latte to do
[Laughter]
okay
goodbye
[Music]
so there is
um an instructional assistant
uh assistant a Florida High School
employee
who is complaining about about a Bible
verse on their co-workers parking space
because it is attacking them
which Bible verses we see the Bible
verse and then they go oh yeah so
there's a there is John 3 16. they pull
up imagine you're pulling up in your
parking spot you look at your co-workers
parking spot next to you there's a Bible
verse
and you're Jewish oh oh okay that's a
ton of them that it could be so this one
says
I hate the Jews I [ __ ] hate the juice
that's what it said Romans Romans 16 13.
whoa gotta be New Testament then no it
says it says Philippians 4 13 which
reads I can do all things through Christ
which strengthens me yeah
so how would that be offensive because
Christ I think I don't know
what is it I was like because he was
handicapped I was like maybe I can't do
all things
oh that's really good oh the levels are
getting deeper when you think about it
Colleen's good dude she's really good
that's very good I don't know it's the
first thing that came to my mind yeah
it's true
why would the Christ part it goes back
to yeah but
he was because he's Jewish you don't
believe in them believe in Jesus Christ
as being a someone who can strengthen
you
so that's an a person I don't think they
believe in Jesus because it's they don't
think he's the second Messiah or
whatever to call it but that makes it a
personal attack uh yeah good guesses so
she says that her parents told her story
of the Holocaust and says that she feels
like this quote is attacking her as a
Jew
but I don't understand how because they
she says it brings back painful memories
I feel like this is a pretty common
Bible verse wait time for memories of
what exactly it brings me to the verge
of tears because it brings me back to
the Six Million that perished but she
wasn't even a part of the Holocaust dude
is she even really Jewish
I'm starting to doubt that she's really
Jewish her last name is Jen telesco so I
think we all know that's a Jewish name I
don't know I don't know if it's
gentleness that's like me going oh when
the Mongols try to evade [ __ ] Japan
but you have some serious trauma about
that yeah you actually cried yeah they
actually but you are from Fields
well you know they recently made a game
called the [ __ ] um the the the the
it's like a it's it's based on the
[ __ ] Mongol invasion on the island
yeah yeah I love that game and it
brought back four memories and I thought
it was very insensitive because my my
culture you know my culture was being uh
spoiler alert at the end of the game you
defeat the Mongols yeah but people were
profiting off of this dude's culture do
they have some stuff to do but it was
still scary time man even though we won
oh you guys won yeah we still oh you
don't get to complain about it that's
scary people still died okay even though
you win a war you still have to people
die on your side casualties yeah for
sure so what'd the guy do about it he
just like duplicated the sign and put
them on every other party you put on
every single parking spot yeah yeah so
then shouldn't by proxy that means every
uh atheist should be upset by a
paper dollar bill that says In God We
Trust when they think of all the
Christian Crusades that have killed tons
of people correct you know there's a
troll group called The Church of Satan I
think it's yeah wait I think they're
luciferians or chip States one's actual
devil worshipers one's a troll group I
never know which one but yeah there's
one of them is really funny
when what they do is they're not real
satanists right but they've used the
whole like non-profit Church
organization system meant for Christians
they developed one for the Church of
just to piss them off they want a Satan
Fountain go next to the Church of Jesus
Christ saying uh I'm found where like
water's coming out of his dick and like
his wings yeah like it's tight like when
they like donate like a big Jesus at
like the city hall they donate like a
big old thing of like Satan that's a
goat and [ __ ] with the pentagram yeah is
that do you guys remember there's a
website back in the day called Church of
euthanasia like euthanasia the word no I
didn't know if that was a troll page
either but it was really [ __ ] Brazen
this was like in the early uh 2000s if
you get went to this page I think the
landing page was like it showed like and
this was like early 2000s it showed the
[ __ ] Twin Towers being hit and it's
and it had like a sounds really familiar
yeah and it said like I love to watch or
something and then you can click through
it and then one of them will have
instructions on how to how to eat
another person how to cook them
correctly oh like crazy [ __ ] I can't
remember this yeah
yeah but it was like kind of uh closet
viral with people like word of mouth
because they were like yo look how crazy
this website is it was like perfect for
our age too we're like people are gonna
cook pigments it's crazy yeah it said a
bunch of stuff like like don't eat
humans unless they're fresh like it's
there's no point to eat a dead human
it's like it has to be a living human
versus no there's no reason
do you know that whole troll group that
does the same thing but with like the
Flying Spaghetti Monster and then they
got rid like church Status Church of the
Flying Spaghetti Buster yeah what the
freak yeah you never seen this fun
Spirit
that's their God you might join careful
yeah pretty compelling stuff careful
dude I'm gonna fall for it but wasn't it
like a group of Skeptics or something
that decided to use the church it's a
spoof yeah yeah it's making the point
that it's just some filings and you can
get it done yeah what that looks like a
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
oh it's it's beta food
so yum yum huh that's what you saw we
all saw the smoke finds pretty Monster
and you saw bit of food I'm absolutely a
beta
what's that oh the spaghetti monster
yeah monster
that's their God yeah it's cool art
though there you go interesting I mean
do you think there'd be enough things
that are offensive on purpose that you
don't have to go mad at a parking space
with a Philippians 4 13 on it you would
think right you would think yeah exactly
no so um they take the concerns you know
the the woman takes the construction the
principal who then goes the district and
then the district says hey look freedom
of expression we're not going to do
anything about this it's it's not a
violation it's personal expression
there's no proselytizing going on the
parking spot is not compelling students
to do anything one way or another yeah
so like good call yeah
yeah but it's like it's just like who
makes a complaint about this dude well
it's just like you know um they were
saying it's just like a teacher
expressing themselves wearing a crucifix
on their shirt or like having a necklace
like what's the [ __ ] difference yeah
there was a case where um
this black kid in a dorm
filed for uh
it was it was what do you call it like
um not hate speech but like
uh the race crimes the [ __ ] brain
fart when you assault someone through
racial means hey cramp hate crime hate
crime why is that so hard to remember
so basically his dorm mate in front of
him was an actual Neo-Nazi so what he
did was he put the swastika up and he
wrote like a sign on his door so every
morning when the black kid opens the
door he sees this so the case went up to
like court and it was like so is this is
this a hate crime what is this and
basically
the fact that he couldn't escape from
that every day because he lives there
and he has to see it that's what made it
um basically hate speech hate crime
but if you were able to choose a place
to be like well I could park in another
space so I could be somewhere else it
doesn't qualify as that but because if
you're forced to see it every day and
you can't have another out then it's
considered that yeah okay I can't
understand that swastika Bible verse it
is a big difference right but you can't
argue that something is offensive to you
you can try but it has to I think fall
under Common Sense yeah well because
this person was not directly involved
with suffering in the Holocaust correct
I mean but she has generational memory
ancestors or something maybe they're
lineage but that Bible verse is such a
stretch I totally I agree but I don't
know I'm just trying to see the other
side yeah like trying to see where like
maybe their great grandfather or
something like that was I just don't
understand how the Christianity and
Holocaust has a connection I think she
just has beef with this person's just
trying to find it that's what I think
she just doesn't like the person yeah
she just doesn't like the person
couldn't find any kind of reason to she
is an instructional assistant I don't
know what the [ __ ] that means so she's a
TA she's not even a real teacher no idea
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here you
temporary employee parking space you
should [ __ ] you're worse than a
substitute teacher we should park off
campus yeah why does she have her own
Park as well just give up parking space
to everybody apparently they do they
were so hard to get when I was in high
school it was so hard to get
how come we can't just write STFU on a
piece of paper and hand it to people I I
would love that
this is a hate crime
STFU how about that that'd be wonderful
you're like no actually this is an
acronym I can't imagine like constantly
walking up to people and being like this
like brings me back to the six million
people who perish like you're constantly
doing oh dude you know what's funny I
heard I had something kind of similar to
happen to me I met this girl and then we
exchanged uh like Facebook and then she
messaged me on my profile at the time it
was like
in my profile pic I'm wearing like this
uh it's like a rope that looks like a
it's a necktie that looks like kind of
rope-ish and she goes hey my um my
sister recently killed herself can you
change your profile pic
always women
how about it clean yeah I just feel like
I had to say it for everybody is it
really well I mean look into the
teleprompter yeah why is it always women
I think you said those do you have a
take do you have a theory on why it
might be I've never had that interaction
so I don't know
I really think there's a there's a gray
area between uh being offended by
somebody and just having a weak
mentality
the core of it is you need to change not
me exactly so that's the core of
everything yeah how recent is the story
uh it's just happened so my theory is
because of all the Kanye stuff she's
like oh I could use this times are hot
yeah I could use this to get this [ __ ]
out of here because I hate her so much
so I'm gonna go to the media and be like
yo you're [ __ ] me over with with this
all this juice stuff talk well isn't
that kind of then that's kind of
indicative of just culture as a whole
right now is like outrage culture is
being like so fed on because people are
seeing results so it's like oh I want
results it kind of got canceled I can
cancel this [ __ ] do you think she's
just drunk at karaoke and she's like
she's like in the music's Lounge she's
like I'm trying to ride the Jew thing
like we'll see how it goes
I think it's really hot right I think
it's hot I think it's gonna work you
know I mean yeah I just found out I'm 30
Jewish and she's like how [ __ ] long
does it take to do get to my song
we've been here for like a [ __ ] hour
and a half
and then she does and then she does Time
to Say Goodbye
thank you
foreign